es muy importante justamente este punto
el fortalecimiento pero castillo se está
sintiendo que el presidente como tal
está teniendo mayor injerencia ya en lo
que es el gobierno porque la percepción
inicial que se tuvo respecto de su
mandato era como que está muy
condicionado al partido que nos lleva
justamente a la presencia a la república
y particularmente ayer desde partido que
es el neurocirujano vladimir cerrón hay
que señalar que se rompe ese es una
persona bastante radical
manifiestamente comunista y una persona
que de hecho se era como una suerte de
espada mote para el presidente porque
incluso el primer premier el ex primer
ministro bellido en una persona de mucha
cercanía a vladimir cerrón y por envío
se hace vida como una puerta partidaria
y en especial de desarrollo muy
importante en el gobierno